on commence par le climat boris vélo le
texte le sénat examinera cet après midi
le texte sur un éventuel référendum
climat le projet de loi
constitutionnelle le sénat n'est pas
d'accord avec l'assemblée hier vous avez
sans doute vu cette une du journal du
dimanche sur un référendum qui serait
enterré ce qu'emmanuel macron a démenti
dans l'après midi à strasbourg en disant
qu'il faut laisser travailler le
parlement est ce que vous croyez encore
qu'un référendum aura lieu
écoutez je crois qu'il est souhaitable
je crois que la cause est suffisamment
importante pour que tout soit mis en
oeuvre pour vous allez dire construire
le conte premier républicain qui
transcende les familles politiques et
qui est comme seul objet la préservation
de notre environnement dans un moment
très grave de déséquilibres
environnementaux et climatiques
donc oui j'ai comme voulu la une d'un
journal généralement bien informé quand
il s'agit ce qui se passe dans le
gouvernement et qui n'était pas
rassurant et qui semblaient tirés par
anticipation les conclusions des débats
parlementaires qui n'est pas achevée est
ce que je m'étonne de la méthode temps
j'ai le sentiment qu'en réalité
l'exécutif tient le débat parlementaire
pour un exercice de style
non mais il faut aller au bout il faut
comme nous l'avons fait nous socialistes
à l'assemblée nationale eh bien le
défendre un texte des formes des
propositions qui vont dans le sens de
celles du gouvernement les sénateurs
socialistes le font ici et je crois que
il faut attendre de voir où nous en
sommes mais je voudrais aller à
l'assemblée vous avez voté vous la
version dû trouver un élément est ce que
vous êtes prêts à un compromis avec la
version du sénat où ce référendum il
doit pas revenu sur la version du
gouvernement à écouter genou que je ne
connais pas encore la version qui
sortira du sénat vous avez vu celle qui
est sortie de la commission et enlever
le mot guerre mentir qui fait référence
est en effet en retrait il faut
continuer de travailler de convaincre je
crois qu'il faut aller à un référendum
si cela doit améliorer le cadre
juridique dans lequel nous allons
ensuite légiférer je crois que tous les
référents conversion la concession la
version la plus ambitieuse possible donc
[Musique]